JEFFREY POSNICK: Hi, I'm Jeffrey
Posnick from the
YouTube API Developer
Relations team.
And I'm here with Dean Jansen
from Amara joining us live
from New York City.
And via Hangout,
we have Arthur.
Hello, Arthur.
ARTHUR DEBERT: [NO AUDIO].
JEFFREY POSNICK: And I'm
having a little trouble
hearing you, Arthur.
Hopefully, we'll
be able to work
through those sound issues.
Arthur's joining us
from Sao Paulo.
And he is the developer working
on Amara, and Dean is
one of the co-founders?
DEAN JANSEN: Yep.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
OK, so we're talking
about Amara.
What is Amara, and how
did you get started?
What's some background?
DEAN JANSEN: Yeah, yeah.
So I guess we've been working on
this piece of software for
about three years now.
Amara is essentially, we think,
the easiest way to
create captions from scratch
or subtitles for videos.
And the beginnings of the
project really were around why
is it so difficult to
create captions?
A lot of the software, while
freely available, can be
difficult to use.
You've got to download it,
install it on your
computer, et cetera.
And so that's kind of what
the birth of Amara was.
And we figured, this is
the internet age.
Why isn't there an easy way to
do this, and why isn't it
collaborative?
And so the whole idea behind
Amara was make it so that you
can take a video from anywhere
on the web, whether it's on
YouTube or Vimeo or hosted on
your own server, plug it into
our platform, and then be up
and running in seconds, and
also be able to engage friends
strangers, volunteers, anyone
on the internet to help you
then translate video.
So a big part of it also is
around collaboration and--
JEFFREY POSNICK: And
crowdsourcing.
DEAN JANSEN: --the Wikipedia
style model, yeah.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
And to be sure I have my
terminology right, is there a
difference between captions
and subtitles?
I don't want to use one
instead of the other.
DEAN JANSEN: That's a really
good question.
And we had a lot of learning to
do also, and I think we're
still learning a lot.
But captions in the US are
oftentimes thought of as
something for someone who is
deaf or hard of hearing that
will have the audio
information.
So if a door slams shut, then
you'd get the door slamming.
Whereas subtitle is, I think,
a bit more of a generic term
and is often used when you're
talking about translated
captions, possibly without
the audio information.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
Thank you for clearing
that up.
So all right, you talked about
the different video platforms
that you integrate with.
And obviously, YouTube shows,
we're very interested in
hearing about your YouTube
integration.
But can we talk a little bit
more about who the target
audience is for your platform?
Who do you find using Amara?
DEAN JANSEN: Yeah.
That's another good question.
Well, of course, I think it's
also worth mentioning, we're a
nonprofit organization.
It's an open source project.
And the reason behind what we're
doing really is to make
it so that video can become
accessible, and not just in
the sense of accessibility for
deaf and hard of hearing, but
also accessibility in a broader
linguistics sense of
translating videos into
as many different
languages as possible.
And so the audiences
are varied.
Someone who's going to be a
consumer of captions or
subtitles is going to be anyone
who doesn't speak a
language, which I'm sure there
are a couple of languages you
don't speak.
I certainly don't speak
a lot of languages.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
DEAN JANSEN: And then we have a
pretty exciting community of
both deaf and hard-of-hearing
people, but also we have a
caption team that's purely
around requests from deaf and
hard-of-hearing users.
So they can basically
say, hey, I'm
interested in this video.
I'd like to have it captioned,
and then people caption it.
So there's a lot of different
viewing audiences.
And then, of course, I think
anyone who's making video is
potentially a creator
audience.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Sure, totally.
And obviously, it goes
without saying,
YouTube is a global platform.
I'm an English-language
speaker.
But I often find myself
interested in content that's
not in English, and it's a real
barrier to me if there
doesn't happen to be
subtitles for that.
So I certainly appreciate it
even as someone who's an
English speaker.
So we've talked a little bit
about content creators.
And let's say I'm not somebody
who would initially think of,
hey, I should be providing
captions or
subtitles for my videos.
What's the value proposition?
Why should I, as a content
creator, really go about
captioning as much
as possible?
DEAN JANSEN: Well, I think if
you strip out a single reason,
then it can be easy
to brush past it.
But when you think about the
broad application of having
same-language subtitles or
captions as well as translated
captions, you start out with
having a basis of better SEO.
So your video is captioned.
You've got more metadata around
the video content.
It's easier for people
to find.
It's easier for you to
go back and refer to.
Well, when we're talking about
drones in that new sequence?
And we can get right there.
On top of that, you have the
accessibility reasons for deaf
and hard-of-hearing folks.
On top of that, you start to
potentially, if you're
engaging volunteers, you're
bringing in folks and engaging
them in a real and meaningful
way in your content.
JEFFREY POSNICK: It seems like
a nice way of building
community around a video.
DEAN JANSEN: Well, the TED Talks
Conference, they have a
humongous volunteer community
of translators.
I think there are 14,000 or
15,000 of them right now.
They're all volunteers.
And TED thinks of that community
as a hugely valuable
part of the overall TED
Conference organization.
And they speak very highly of
the people who are putting in
their time and effort and a lot
of hard work to translate
the 12,000 or 15,000 TED Talks
and 20,000 TEDx Talks.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
And this is obviously one of
the more scalable ways of
doing that.
That's a very daunting process
if you have one person.
One person who happens to know
dozens of languages sitting at
a keyboard, that doesn't
scale very well.
DEAN JANSEN: Right.
So to get back to your question,
even someone who's a
content creator that has a
popular YouTube channel, let's
say, and may not know a lot of
reason to do this, if they
want to get a more global
audience, this is a way not
only to get your video subtitled
into different
languages, but also to have
ambassadors, potentially, in
these other languages.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And this is the
sort of thing that's hard
to come up with really strong
metrics about, but certainly,
I would assume that this
increases viewer engagement.
It just really raises the
potential audience from just
everybody who can speak one
language to a much wider
global audience.
DEAN JANSEN: This was your
trickiest question, I think.
This is something that because
we're not the primary viewing
platform, you can come on to
Amara and watch videos in
different languages.
But I think a lot of times,
people are syncing subtitles
back to YouTube, let's say.
Or on ted.com, they're
hosting them.
They're caching them
on their side.
So a lot of the metrics we
actually don't have access to.
We would love it if YouTube
started making some of this
stuff more public or even a
broad summary of here's what
we're seeing across
lots of videos.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
That's something I'd like to
follow up with internally,
definitely.
OK, so hopefully, folks are
aware of the power of captions
and why going about
captioning your
videos is pretty important.
Could we actually dive into
a demo of how you
could Amara to do that?
DEAN JANSEN: Absolutely.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And I
might have to unlock
for you right now.
But if we could pull up the
demo, I think we should be
good to go.
DEAN JANSEN: All right.
So I chose a nice and
non-copyrighted Creative
Commons video for us to
experiment with here.
I'll jump over to the
Amara website.
I guess right now, there's
a lot going on right now.
But the most important thing
is there's a box right here
that says put a URL in
and click subtitle.
So I'll go back to
my YouTube tab.
I'm going to copy the
URL here of this
Creative Commons video.
I'll paste it in, press
Subtitle, and fingers crossed--
bingo.
OK, so this is an Amara
video page.
This is the home base
for the video.
And if you're wanting to invite
other folks in, this is
where you'd point them.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
So again, you can put any
video ID you want here.
It's not necessarily something
in your own channel.
It might be something that
you're just interested in, and
you want to engage
the community in
crowdsourcing the captions.
DEAN JANSEN: Yes.
Right.
And so, yeah.
And it can be pretty much
any kind of video, any
format that you want.
So I'm just going to click on
the Subtitle Me button, and
then it's going to ask what
language is the video in.
It's in English.
We're going to subtitle
into English.
And there's a little tutorial
video that I won't go into.
Let's see.
So this is the interface.
This is pretty much all
HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
Of course, the video itself,
I think, may be Flash.
But it doesn't require Flash.
Any modern browser
will use this.
I think we're in Chrome
right now.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Hopefully,
you're using the iframe player
API, which will use the HTML5
video for playback.
I haven't double-checked that,
but we can talk about the
technical aspects with Arthur.
DEAN JANSEN: We'll ask Arthur,
and we've got a new editor
that we're just about to
start rolling out.
So I think that if we're not
doing it now, we will be.
OK, so to start with, I think
for anyone who's done
captioning, this may or
may not look familiar.
But the process is oftentimes
set in point, type out what
you hear, set out point, next.
And so we've broken it into
three distinct steps that
break that apart.
The first is just transcribing
everything you hear and laying
it all out.
So I'll do one line here just to
show how it works, and then
I've got another window that
has more work done.
So I just play here.
I'll rewind.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What it mean to be
human if we don't
have a shared culture?
What is a shared--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFFREY POSNICK: So
being a speedy
typer is pretty important.
DEAN JANSEN: So the interesting
thing is that
we've got a thing here called
magical autopause that's one
of the modes.
So as long as I'm typing, I'm
doing a little bit of movement
of the cursor to
keep it typing.
When I let off, it's going to
say, OK, you're done typing
and unpause the video
for me and rewind it
just a little bit.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Oh, that's
quite nice, OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-A shared culture--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DEAN JANSEN: There it goes.
And so I can just keep typing,
and it will watch the
background of my typing and
pause and unpause for me.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That's really
nice integration.
DEAN JANSEN: So once I've got
everything typed out in this
other window--
oh, let's see if this
is going to work.
Successfully resumed editing--
yeah, all right.
Nice.
So in this one, I've typed
out a bunch of lines.
You just go through.
You type out all of
the dialogue.
Then you go to the
second step.
I've got another
helpful video.
The second step is modeled
after a video game.
It's like Dance Dance
Revolution.
And the idea is that you're just
tapping every time you
hear what's the dialogue, and
it's going to time the lines
out for you.
So I'll just do a couple
of these lines so we
can see how it works.
And I don't know if you're
able to hear it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What does it mean to
be human if we don't
have a shared culture?
And what does a shared culture
mean if you can't share it?
-So it's only in the last 100 or
150 years or so that we've
started tightly restricting how
that culture gets used.
-The internet enabled
an infrastructure--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DEAN JANSEN: So I'll
pause that.
And the last thing that I think
is worth showing quickly
is the final step, which is the
review where you're able
to just go in and fine
tune things.
So if I've timed something late,
it's like a nonlinear
video editor.
I'm able to hop in, change
everything up.
If I made a mistake, I
can easily edit it,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's pretty intuitive and a
simple interface, and we've
seen people as young as eight
years old use this thing.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
That's awesome.
I've obviously interacted with
YouTube captions before, and
I've done some API
integration.
And I know it as having to
provide this data file that
has time codes and everything
like that.
So having this whole automated
process for generating that
seems like a huge win.
So that's very cool.
And it's really nice
integration, too.
DEAN JANSEN: And once you're
done, you submit your work.
You can then download
the SRT files.
We provide a lot of
different formats.
You can upload those onto
YouTube, and now we'll talk,
I'm sure, about the YouTube
syncing integration as well.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Excellent.
Cool.
So thanks so much for
showing that demo.
Hopefully, we have Arthur via
Hangout, and I'd like to say
hello again.
Arthur, can you hear me OK?
ARTHUR DEBERT: Yeah,
perfectly fine.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
So I can hear you now, so that
is definitely a lot better
than earlier on the show.
So thanks so much
for joining us.
I know that you're one of the
developers who was working on
this open source project.
I guess, first of all, it's
interesting that this is all
an open source project.
So if folks are interested in
looking at some or all of the
code, how would they go
about doing that?
ARTHUR DEBERT: It's on GitHub.
It's
github.com/pculture/unisubs.
I'll paste the link
on the chat.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, and we'll
add that to this video
description also, maybe
do a nice annotation.
Or maybe it will show up in the
captions for this video.
This definitely is a video that
we should get captioned.
Cool.
So, OK.
I saw a really wide range
of different YouTube API
integrations there, Arthur.
So can you talk a little bit
more about which are the APIs
you are using?
ARTHUR DEBERT: Yeah.
We use YouTube API in a bunch
of places, actually.
So when you're adding videos
to Amara, basically our
servers are using Version 2
of the API, which is the
Atom-based one, to gather
data about that video.
Everything from is this
video private?
Can we view it?
Then metadata, the title,
description, and [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
So that's how we register that
video on our website.
As soon as you add the video, we
pull every caption that the
video has on YouTube already.
Not the auto-created ones,
but the ones that are
user-generated on YouTube.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And that's part
of the standard v2 API
that anybody could do for
pulling the captions.
ARTHUR DEBERT: Exactly.
It's the part of the captions
API which is just standard, so
we pull those in.
Whatever you have already on
your video on YouTube, it's
going to be there on Amara.
So it's nice because if any
subtitling work has been done
on YouTube, once you add it to
Amara, the work isn't lost.
It's already there.
So that's using the regular
API, captions API,
to bring them in.
That's pretty much
on the back end.
When you are using our tool
to subtitle the video--
or we also allow you to embed
the video anywhere else-- on a
website, on a blog, just
like [INAUDIBLE]--
we are obviously interfacing
heavily with
the JavaScript API.
JEFFREY POSNICK: The
Player APIs.
ARTHUR DEBERT: The
JEFFREY POSNICK: Are
you actually
using the iframe player?
Do you know if you're using
that or the older--
ARTHUR DEBERT: The iframe
player is in beta.
We are now using, I think, the
iframe player only on Android,
because we'd just rather
not use Flash.
It depends.
We are slowly moving to
the iframe player.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
We're out of the experimental
mode for the iframe player
now, which we were in for an
extended period of time.
So at this point, it's
definitely what I'd recommend
using for both desktop
web-based
interfaces and also on mobile.
So you can talk a
look at that.
ARTHUR DEBERT: And there is just
another use of the Player
API that's interesting that
we're doing is that you can
embed the video plus the Amara
widget on your website.
Sometimes, let's say you already
have a blog with
dozens of YouTube videos, and
you don't want to go back to
your blog and change all the
embed codes to our embed code.
You can use something we
call the widgetizer.
It's just one JavaScript
you insert.
And as soon as we load, we are
going to look at the page to
see if there's any
YouTube video.
And you hook up into the already
embedded YouTube video
and load our widget
together with it.
So it can attach to an already
playing YouTube video.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And that
widget will display the
captions out of bound?
ARTHUR DEBERT: Yeah.
it's going to show
those captions anyway.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Very cool.
So in terms of programming
languages, there's obviously a
bunch of JavaScript on the
Player side of things.
What language are you using to
interface with the Data API?
ARTHUR DEBERT: At the back
end, we are using Python.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
I know that using Python with
our older Data API is a bit of
a challenge in some regards,
so thanks for
bearing with us there.
At this portion of the show, I
would normally tell people,
hey, maybe you should check
out our newer Version
3 of the Data API.
Unfortunately, one of the things
that we have not yet
managed to port over to Version
3 the Data API is
support for the captions.
So that is something that very
legitimately still requires
use of our older Data API.
But I'm certainly hopeful, at
least, it will be added to
Version 3 before too
much longer.
So stay tuned for that.
We make announcements about that
sort of thing on our blog
and Google+ feed and
that sort of place.
So any general feedback that you
have about the development
process, any gotchas that you
want to point out to other
developers who might either be
looking at your code and
trying to learn from it or
trying to do similar things
themselves?
ARTHUR DEBERT: Well, I think
the Data API, the older
versions were a bit
hard to work with.
They were a bit for both.
They are not very Pythonic,
I think.
In general, within the Python
ecosystem, they are a bit off
place there.
But in general, it works.
You just need to be careful.
It's reasonably documented,
and things are pretty
predictable.
I think at the scale we
work, we sometimes--
API quotas and smaller things
that once you get a bit big,
they start to be a concern.
But in general, everything
has been pretty smooth.
The only thing I would say,
depending if you are doing
deep captions integration,
YouTube uses foreign language
codes PCP-47, which is
the same standard
that XMl:lang uses.
And while it's a very
good standard,
it's also a bit complex.
So if you're doing a lot of
back and forth between
subtitles, you just might want
to watch out for that because
the way the standard does,
locator-specific and just
language definitions
is a bit wonky.
It's something to be wary of.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
That's definitely very good
feedback to be aware of.
Cool.
At this point, I actually wanted
to quickly check to see
whether we had any questions
on Google Moderator for
anybody who might we
watching this show.
I'm going to pull that
up real quick.
And OK, so there are a couple
that might be a little off
topic, but there is one here
from Sparkyish saying,
"Awesome stuff.
Obviously, this setup is
for on-demand videos.
Any plans to tackle live video
streaming with a similar setup
and speed demon typists?"
We're broadcasting right
now as part of
YouTube live platform.
Have you been in any discussions
with anybody on
our end about YouTube lives or
other types of streams and
captioning there?
DEAN JANSEN: Have not
yet, but I think
that's an exciting idea.
It certainly has come up before
and is something that
we'd love to explore.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely,
yeah.
And I don't think we are ready
to yet on the YouTube Live
platform necessarily, but
there's always the ability to
have captions that are out of
bound from the video and that
sort of thing.
So, yeah, definitely a very
interesting topic.
OK, so thanks so much for taking
time to go into the
system, Arthur.
I'm sorry I cut you a little
bit off there.
Hopefully, you got through all
the topics that you wanted to
cover on the technical
side of things.
And thanks so much, Dean, for
joining us in person and
talking about Amara.
We will make sure that this
video is captioned.
DEAN JANSEN: Sounds good.
JEFFREY POSNICK: We could
go through the whole
Amara system as well.
DEAN JANSEN: Great.
Yeah, we can try and get it
translated in the couple
different languages.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Awesome.
Very cool.
One last thing, we plug at the
end of most of our shows that
Google Developer Relations,
which is the team that I'm on,
is hiring, as always.
So if you're interested in doing
the same sort of things
that I'm doing, going on camera
and helping developers
and chatting with people doing
cool API integrations,
checkout
developers.google.com/jobs.
So that's it for this week.
Join us next week for
our upcoming show.
Cheers, everybody.
ARTHUR DEBERT: Thank you, guys.
Later.
DEAN JANSEN: Thanks.